daran I'll start with you so much of
what makes things work is just timing in
this business and now we have people
can't leave their homes Netflix is
suddenly running everything in our lives
as exec producer of this how incredible
is this timing I'd be pretty suspicious
of me and Netflix right about this is
this is oddly beneficial you listen I
think all of us who are anybody that has
any remote leg up from this horrible
pandemic you know I think all of us
would have preferred it not to comment
this horrible cost obviously for
millions of lives and public health
concerns and a faltering economy those
are not the variables that you want to
put in the algorithm of success so I
should hope that in a world where this
wasn't part of the equation that the
show would still offer a similar escape
route for a lot of people who are just
feeling you know trapped by their own
world anyway I think one of the great
ironies about the show coming out now is
that it is so we give 1940s Hollywood
the the Hollywood treatment right the
what-if fantasy and it and when we watch
it were kind of swept off our feet to
this other time in this other place and
and it kind of feels like a 1940's movie
in and of itself and the crazy sort of
parallel universe thing that I just
realized during this press junket is
that those films that took swept us off
her feet from the 1940s were coming out
of wartime and we're appealing to people
who are looking to escape a world
outside that was facing an invisible
enemy
I mean more moreso to the people the
United States obviously people in other
parts of the world felt it more on the
home front but for for Americans
particularly who were involved in
Hollywood you know it was this thing
outside they they couldn't do anything
about people would go away and you know
the health workers and people who are
working in places away from from us that
are doing the real thing yeah you know
we don't see them right in front of us
in our homes and so you know
the way that the 40's took people to a
fantastical more hopeful place we kind
of are doing the same thing if the
invisible enemy is this pandemic that we
that were fighting globally so hopefully
we can offer the same service that
Hollywood has offered for the past 80
plus years which is you know scape ISM
and reminding us of where we can be
better and where we are our greatest you
know because while the show does you
know explore and identify the problems
that that Hollywood's and institutions
like it have always had it also
celebrates the people who have been
resilient through all throughout all the
decades that have that have broken
through those ceilings and crashed
through those walls and I think you know
seeing those play out in such a
glamorous fun place like the 1940s it's
just a joy Laura so much of this movie
is your character wanting to see herself
reflected in Hollywood and on the big
screen do you remember the first time
you felt that the first time you saw you
in a movie I mean I think you know
growing up as a black woman that was
always a struggle they were definitely
characters and actors that I identified
with and looks up to you know people
like Halle Berry er Angela Bassett or
Nia long and Lisa Bonet but it was
definitely always a struggle so that's I
think was something really important in
Camille's journey is seeing how much
representation matters and what could
have you know little black girls who
were struggling in their lives have felt
had they been able to see the glamorous
intelligent beautiful black woman on
screen and so how would that made people
dream bigger and hope for more but I
also definitely watched a lot of Cosby
hope growing up so and Samarra both you
and Laura it's it's it's interesting
because you guys are okay so you're
actors playing actors who then take on
roles yeah
yes what is that what is that like when
you walk into work at any given day
where you're like okay what is the voice
today what am i doing well the voice was
actually helpful because they had the
time on films they were taught to speak
in a mid mid-atlantic accent which is
slightly British by the American so when
we had scenes that were it's confusing
me already when we had scenes as actors
playing actors we used that voice and
then when we had scenes where we were
just actors talking to other actors we
used the other from American from
America American actors just use the
regular voices and I used my American
accent so I had a oh yeah it's
incredible you guys all did an amazing
job this show is fantastic and I don't
know if this would have gone any better
had we been all face to face so I cannot
thank you guys enough for this and and
take it easy I really appreciate your
time